israel cerrado por coronavirus desde la
medianoche del lunes al martes el país
prohibirá el tráfico aéreo durante una
semana tan solo habrá excepciones
humanitarias el objetivo es evitar que
entre alguna de las nuevas variantes de
kobe 19 a diferencia de lo que se dice
estamos por delante del mundo entero
ningún país ha hecho lo que vamos a
hacer los sur cerrado por aire y por
tierra el país continúa en un severo
confinamiento hasta febrero lo que sí
que avanzan son las vacunas israel ya ha
inoculado al 25% de su población de 9
millones desde este domingo se pueden
vacunar mayores de 40 años y también con
permiso paterno adolescentes entre 16 y
18 años de este modo podrán volver a la
escuela y realizar sus exámenes
las vacunas ya están aquí tengo mis
exámenes finales en unas pocas semanas
así que sentía que tenía que vacunar me
sin embargo la vacunación despierta
críticas internacionales israel se niega
a inocular a la población palestina
amnistía internacional human right watch
la onu han emplazado a los acuerdos de
oslo de 1990 para vacunar a los
palestinos según éstos israel debe
cooperar para combatir epidemias
condenamos el racismo del estado de
ocupación se jactan de la rapidez de
vacunar a sus ciudadanos y descuidan la
responsabilidad de inocular a las
personas bajo ocupación del mismo auto
niega denuncias que se suman a la
dificultad que está teniendo israel con
su población ultra-ortodoxa ésta
significa poco más del 10 por ciento de
sus habitantes sin embargo se niegan a
obedecer el confinamiento y rechazan
cualquier vacunación